5 j'ai tendance à penser que s'inquiéter
j'ai un très grand nombre sérieusement
quand je regarde cinq cartes
je suis pas capable de les compter d'un
seul coup je suis obligé au moins dans
ma tête de les séparer en un ensemble de
deux à un ensemble de trois fois je sais
pas si vous êtes aussi mauvais que moi
mais bref
5 c'est pas du tout le genre de nombre
dont j'ai envie de vous parler
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va parler des nombreux
super méga ultra géant
commençons par une gourde d'eau le
nombre de molécules qui lie à dans cette
bourde est à peu près 10 puissance 25 et
10 puissance 25 c'est un nombre grand
même super grand c'est un nombre qui en
fait littéralement astronomique puisque
c'est à peu près le nombre des toiles
dont l'univers en fait il ya tellement
de molécules d'eau dans cette gourde
qu'avec une grande probabilité même une
très très grande probabilité environ
1000 des molécules dans cette bourde se
trouvait dans le dernier verre d'eau de
jésus-christ comme en parle si bien
david sur son site au nantes et ça quand
on y réfléchit c'est super étrange non
et bien si c'est si étrange que ça c'est
parce que 10 puissance 25 ans fait un
nombre très difficile à imaginer
on peut même dire de ce nombre qu'il est
la limite de ce que l'on peut calculer
aujourd'hui nous connaissons environ 10
puissance 14 décimales de pi et je ne
doute pas que dans les années à venir on
arrivera en calcul et 10 puissance 25
peut-être même plus mais pas beaucoup
plus tout simplement parce que même les
ordinateurs n'auront pas le temps
d'écrire ses 10 puissance 25 décimales
il est environ 10 puissance 7 secondes
dans une année donc même avec 1
milliards d'opérations par seconde sur
un millier
d'ordinateur nous ne pouvons qu écrire
dix puits sont cette fois 10 puissance
sont 9 fois 10 puissance 9 soit 10
puissance 25 décimales par an donc
disposant de 25 c'est un nombre qui est
vraiment énorme
en gros on peut dire que c'est la limite
du big data mais pour un mathématicien à
des substances 25 ce n'est vraiment
qu'une goutte d'eau quasiment
littéralement même un nombre comme le
google qui est 10 puissance son reste
encore un nombre assez compréhensible
pour un mathématicien
oui c'est vrai à 10 puissance et déjà
plus grand que le nombre de particules
dans l'univers mais un mathématicien se
contre fout complètement de notre mieux
heures par exemple si je prends un jeu
de 78 cartes alors que nombre de
mélanges possibles de ces cartes est
déjà plus grands clubs du golfe
or 78 c'est un tout petit nombre en tête
en combinatoire ce domaine des
mathématiques qui cherchent à compter le
nombre d'arrangements d'objets google
est assez petit on arrive en fait
rapidement
elle dénombre aussi super méga géant que
le googleplex googleplex c'est nice
puissance en google 30 ans 10 1 1 suivi
d'un google 2 0 c'est absolument énorme
si elle norme qui n'est en fait pas
assez de particules dans l'univers pour
écrire ce nombre en effet il faudra un
google de symboles pour pouvoir écrire
ce nombre or dans notre univers il y a
moins d'un google de particules c'est
assez impressionnant
et pourtant ceci ne suffit pas je pense
faire justice
l'immensité du googleplex comme
l'expliquent très bien cette superbe
vidéo de number five si je marche
googleplex de mettre dans une direction
alors je finirai par rencontrer une
copie identique de moi même et ça c'est
parce que le googleplex est beaucoup
plus grand que le nombre d'arrangements
de particules dans un espace de la
taille de mon corps donc juste par
l'inévitabilité de la loi des grands
nombres avec très très grande
probabilité
parmi l'un des googleplex des espaces
qui font la taille de décor il y en aura
au moins un qui sera parfaitement
identiques à mon corps et ça c'est super
bizarre je veux dire si le mec qui a un
googleplex de m dans cette direction est
exactement comme moi
d'un point de vue physique c'est à dire
que d'un point de vue biologique aussi
exactement comme moi
et du coup il ya le même look que moi
est la même odeur que moi et même penser
que moi il a les mêmes souvenirs que moi
il a les mêmes ambitions que moi
s'il venait à me remplacer ici personne
ne veut faire la différence
personne ne pourrait voir la différence
c'est si étrange que j'en viens même à
me demander qu'est ce qui fait que je
suis moi et pas lui
qu'est ce qui fait que je me sens être
moi je me sens différent de lui vous ne
sont pas être lui
alors qu'aucun principe de la physique
ne permet de nous distinguer vous vous
souvenez dans l'épisode 25 que vous avez
dit qu'un univers infini me poser
problème en fait pas besoin d'un univers
infini suffit que l'univers face
googleplex de m pas le cas de l'univers
observable mais peut-être que l'univers
tout entier fait en effet plus d'un
googleplex de mètres de large et si tel
est le cas chez des questions
métaphysiques qui n'ont pas de réponse
je sais pas comment déterminer la nature
de la conscience à partir de principes
physiques et ça ça me pose problème et
je suis perdu si on a la tête qui
tournait j'espère que vous aussi vous
avez la tête qui tourne en pensant à
dénombre aussi grand que le googleplex
et pourtant le googleplex n'ai encore
rien dans l'immensité du monde
mathématiques
passons maintenant au nombre de g dans
les années 70 rands g a introduit un
nombre super méga géant pour résoudre un
tauren d'ap ans ultra simple dont je
peux pas l'expliquer moi même
ron g l'expliqué dans cette superbe
vidéo de nos morts fall et je vais pas
l'expliquer parce que j'ai prévu de
finir comme maître parker dans cette
vidéo ne meurt pas mais je vais vous
faire remarquer que le seul nombre qui à
apparaître dans le théorème en question
et le nombre quatre îles pour résoudre
ce problème qui ne fait intervenir que
le nombre 4 rhône cram a dû inventer un
nombre si gargantuesque que s'il
essayait de mémoriser tous les chiffres
de ce nombre
mon cerveau devrait finir par se
transformer en un trou noir
oui parce qu'il ya une limite physique à
la quantité d'informations que l'on peut
mettre dans un volume d espace donner ça
à voir avec l'entreprise des trous noirs
donc je n'ai pas parlé dans cet épisode
bref cette limite la quantité
d'informations que l'on peut mettre dans
un volume d espace est énorme et comparé
au nombre de g c'est absolument rien
alors qu'est ce que nombre de g dans la
première étape de la construction du
nombre de grammes consiste à calculer
l'expression d'apparence très simple
suivante trois flèches flèche pleisch
flèche 3 et qu'est ce que c'est que ce
nom voilà ça me fait tellement megannem
que je sais pas le temps d'écrire
concentrons-nous pour l'instant sur
trois flèches flèche flèche 3 qui comme
va le voir et déjà monstrueusement plus
géant que le googleplex
alors qu'est ce que veulent dire ces
flèches les trois flèches veulent dire
que cette expression peut être
décomposée en une suite de deux flèches
si j'ai un point d'interrogation suivi
des trois flèches et d'un siège c'est à
dire que je peut décomposer ça ensuite
de points d'interrogations et de deux
flèches ou le point d'interrogation
apparaît dies fois sur cette expression
ainsi le 3 qui tout à gauche veut dire
que la suite de deux flèches ne contient
que des 3 alors que l'e3 qui est à
droite de l'expression de gauche veut
dire qu'il n'y en a que trois de sorte
que trois flèches flèche play3 est égal
à 3 flash flash trois flèches flèche 3
les parenthèses commence à droite on
peut maintenant des composés cette
expression en une flèche trois flèches
flash flex 3 est égal à 3 flèches flèche
trois flèches flèche 3 et saas est égale
à une suite de trois séparés par d une
flèche
combien y at-il de 3 dans cette
expression avec d une flèche
il y en a trois flèches flèche 3 et 3
flèches flèche 3
ça c'est égal une suite de trois et deux
une flèche
combien y at-il de 3 dans cette
expression il y en a 3 c'est le 3 qui
apparaît à droite dans l'expression avec
les deux flèches et du coup trois
flèches flèche 3 est égal à 3 flèches
trois flèches 3 ça y est on y est on a
une expression où il n'ya plus que d une
crèche
mais que signifie la une flèche eh bien
il s'agit de l'expo annonciation tout
sorte que trois flèches flèche 3 qui
était égal à 3 flèches trois flèches 3
est égal à 3 ^ 3 ^ 3 alors 3 ^ 3 est
égale à 27
du coup ceux ci est égal à trois
puissances 27 et ça c'est à peu près
égale à 7 soit 10 puissance 12 soit 7000
milliards
c'est pas mal déjà eh bien ce n'est
absolument rien comparé à 3 flèches
flèche flèche 3 3 flèches flèche flèche
3 est égal à 3 flèches trois flèches
trois flèches explique qu'il est égal à
3 ^ 3 ^ 3 ^ 3 ^ 3 ^ 3 ^ propre science
profession de conditions strictes 3,83
combien y at-il de 3 dans cette colonne
d'exploration il y en a sept mille
milliards ce nombre est stupidement
gargantuesque
il est beaucoup plus gigantesque que le
googleplex qui ne combine est que trois
expos nantiat sion ici il n'y en a des
lle 2 milliards et pourtant ne s'agit
que de trois flèches plaisent plh 3
la première étape du calcul du nombre de
gran
souvenez-vous contenait quatre flèches
g1 est égal à 3 flèches flèche flèche
flèche
3 et ça je ne sais absolument pas
comment le décrire est pourtant encore
une fois ce n'est que la première étape
de la construction du nombre de g
deuxième étape de la construction et 92
g consiste à reprendre 1,3 avec des
flèches un autre 3
combien de flash ou est il ya voir
aggrave ainsi de remettre j'ai une j'ai
une pêche entre 3 et pourquoi sachant
que gerin est un nombre qui est
tellement énorme que je ne connais même
pas d'une façon de le décrire je sais
pas si vous vous rendez coûte à chaque
fois qu'on aura ajouté une flèche pour
passer de trois ou quatre flèches une
explosion énorme du nombre qu'est ce que
ça donne si au lieu de prendre quatre
flèches j'en prends maintenant un nombre
qui est tellement grand que j'avais même
pas ça me dépasse plus généralement gn
+1 correspond à prendre gn flèche entre
1 3 et 1 3 comprenez donc bien que peu
importe la taille de gênes c'est
absolument rien compris j'ai une plus
sain que le nombre de g correspond âgés
de 64 qui est un nombre mais je ne sais
même pas pourquoi est-ce qu'on invente
ce genre de nombres c'est un truc de
bien et je conçois dénombre de plus en
plus ben pour moi quand je lis ça j'ai
un massacre ont fait juste n'importe hop
au moment pile des trucs pour faire des
trucs qui ont aucun sens ce qui aurait
représenté un truc qui m'aurait
forcément acquis on est gros mais y'a
aucune façon de se représenter la taille
de son ce nombre n'a aucun sens pour moi
et je pense qu'il ne devra avoir de sens
pour personne
là on entre tout simplement dans un
monde qui semble transcender les
mathématiques compréhensible le plus
étrange le plus fou c'est que nombre de
grammes a été utile
depuis mmd nombre encore plus grand que
l'on de g qui ont été inventés et ont
été utiles pour prouver des toiles la
thématique
mais ces nombres qui semble
littéralement déraisonnable on leur
applique encore une
que l'on a déduit des petits nombres
qu'on al'habitude de calcul et de
manipuler dans notre quotidien est ce
qu'on a le droit de faire ça est ce
qu'on a le droit d'étendre la logique
que l'on à un ferrer de notre quotidien
à ses ouailles aux ultras distant et
éloigné de toute chose que l'on connaît
bien dans cette série je vais chercher à
vous convaincre qu'il est très difficile
d'être vraiment convaincu de quoi que ce
soit
lorsque l'on cherche à raisonner
purement de façon logique en fait ce que
je vais essayer de vous montrer c'est
que la logique n'a absolument rien de
lui ou gic
elle espère que vous avez aimé cet
épisode la prochaine fois on va parler
de l'égalité 09 79 ou est égal à 1
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
la ligue et elle a commenté elle a
partagé
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes j'espère que
vous verrez la prochaine fois il n'y a
même pas de mots dans la langue
française dans n'importe quelle autre
langue pour pouvoir décrire ça c'est un
début